escoltados por vehículos blindados rusos
estos soldados salen de la planta
siderúrgica de azov sal hacia un destino
incierto según moscú los combatientes
ucranianos fueron llevados a la colonia
penitenciaria en territorio controlado
por los separatistas apoyados por el
kremlin según el jefe de la
autoproclamada república de donges que
los combatientes ucranianos de alto
rango siguen escondidos en la fábrica
según nuestra información había más de
2.000 personas en la fábrica soft al
salieron 265 combatientes luego 617 algo
más de la mitad de ellos se quedaron
dentro en cuanto a los criminales de
guerra y los nacionalistas si deponen
las armas su destino estará en manos de
la justicia
según moscú estas imágenes muestran a
los soldados ucranianos siendo tratados
en un hospital de la región de donges
que el vídeo fue filmado editado y
publicado por el ministerio de defensa
ruso
estudié en un hospital de la ciudad de
novasoft me tratan bien nadie me
maltrata físicamente o psicológicamente
me revisaron la pierna me dijeron que
estaba bien nos dieron comida
la propaganda rusa presenta estos
hombres como miembros del batallón hace
combatientes integrados en el ejército
ucraniano
afirmaciones utilizadas por el gobierno
ruso para justificar la guerra en
ucrania por ahora se han revelado pocos
detalles del acuerdo del 16 de mayo
entre kiev y moscú que propició la
rendición de los combatientes según
moscú o la evacuación a según kiev
ucrania espera ahora poder hacer un
intercambio de prisioneros